la polémique de la semaine les amis les
mariages de stars les plus chères au
monde c'est hallucinant là encore je
sais bien en fait ce qu'on veut de son
pognon mais est-ce que parfois c'est pas
un peu indécent parce que parfois il
faut pas un peu penser aux autres
en tout cas moi c'est ce que je commence
à croire aujourd'hui en vieillissant et
il était temps comme tu dis donc on va
prêts à vous parler de deux passions de
magali forcément donc l'argent et
l'argent là cette semaine la chanteuse
katy perry revenu sur la façon dont
orlando bloom orlando bloom la demande
en mariage on a assez intriguant ainsi
pardon appris que l'acteur avait dépensé
sans compter
hélicoptère champagne bague à 5 millions
de dollars une demande qui annonce
forcément une cérémonie exceptionnelle
hors de prix dont voici un récapitulatif
de quelques mariages de stars parmi les
plus chères au monde
est-ce qu'il faut montrer qu'on a du
pognon pour montrer qu'on est célèbre
regardez
selon certains témoignages le mariage
serait le plus beau jour d'une sous
[Musique]
enfin c'est ce que certains disent
et puis il ya mariage et mariage parce
que forcément chez les people ont fait
les choses encore élevage et les
carrosses lestrem les illico les
débauches de fleurs et on invite toute
la famille et les copains sauf à être
chiche
pour charles et diana en 1981 comptait
110 millions de dollars
walt coucou
[Musique]
kate et william en 2011 cette jolie
aussi 34 millions de dollars
megan et harry l'année dernière 42
millions quand même et pourtant la
chapelle saint georges à windsor c'était
gratos ça fait moins de frais d'ailleurs
pour la musique c'est le poteau idris
elba qui a mis l'ambiance
paris le comédien quoi
[Applaudissements]
georges et amal ont adoré et
contrairement aux bruits qui ont couru
vous avez joué bien poule non non on
appela jo bière pong et si on y avait
joué imaginer la fin de la soirée
le mariage de georges et amal d'ailleurs
à venise il était super aussi petit prix
13 millions de dollars balade en bateau
homard au menu et trois chansons de lana
del rey comprise dans la catégorie fou
fou à 12 millions de dollars kim
kardashian et kanye west
ils avaient convié leurs invités au
château de versailles je me suis tout
une blague et vert c'était une surprise
tout le monde et mieux à paris et on est
parti à florence et de vie n'était venu
chanter au mariage lana del rey et well
and haas hold up pour animer vos parties
bon compte et 300 mille dollars la
chanson mais notre conseil tpm people
sachets demander gentiment
fan très combien que vous faire voir mon
mariage pour vous je peux le faire
gratuitement s'offrira un mariage hors
de prix c'est cool on c'est naze c'est
dans les questions jeunes composent un
peu maintenant c'est pas valérie bègue
c'est cool ou nahd
donc voilà sur frais des mariages des
cercles plus cher quelques exemples un
charles et diana 100 millions d'euros
harry et mégane 37 millions william et
kate 34 albert et charlene 20 millions
jorge et amal clooney 13 millions
d'euros
kanye west et kim kardashian 12 millions
c'est quand même assez hallucinant alors
voilà est-ce que c'est bien est-ce que
c'est pas bien ce qu on fait ce qu'on
veut de son argent ou est-ce qu'un
moment c'est indécent vis-à-vis d euros
trouvés à vis de ceux qui n'ont rien je
ne juge pas je pose la question
guy tout pour moi j'aime j'aime pas le
principe de dépenser de l'argent de le
montrer comme ça pour un mariage il ya
un moment les kardashian 12 millions je
trouve ça personnellement indécent en
revanche pour ce qui est des royaux ça
c'est différent ça rapporte tellement ça
rapporte des milliards à la couronne
britannique couronne britannique les
mariages des princes
ils sont faits pour ça ils sont faits
pour être des vitrines pour s'exposer
pour ce congrès dont vue parfaite de 50
millions de paires la série par des
milliards de téléspectateurs donc peu
c'est normal ça rapporte c'est ccc des
biens d'état en revanche oui kanye west
et kardashian clip aux 12 millions pour
un mariage c'est un descendant des bleus
monde est en crise je trouve ça indécent
mais c'est comme c'est comme une actu
c'est comme la sortie d'un album c'est
un coup de projecteur la maison commune
ouest et machin dont j'ai besoin d'eux
et de toute façon dans une vidéo porno
c'est le mari donc c'était comprendre
c'est qu'il ya souvent cette espèce de
concours qui est tien je sais pas yaya
machin tel acteur qaf1r 13 donc moi je
vais faire un mariage à 14 je vous
raconter une anecdote qui n'a rien à
voir mais qu un peu bête
il y avait un attaché de presse qui
m'avait raconté que quand on est invité
dans des cérémonies au théâtre et tout
ça on est classé au premier deuxième
troisième rang et quand les people
arrivent ils regardent et quand parfois
tu as un à guillou n'importe quoi qui
voit qu'il au quatrième rang alors que
le sabatier est au troisième il le prend
très mal parce qu'ils considèrent qu'il
est un rang derrière c'est bon vous dire
légaux de tous ces stars ça se joue avec
de l'argent avec db6 c'est hallucinant
donc ça peut choquer pourquoi c'est cool
pour vous 4 et noir
c'est cool de claquer 10 pognon tous les
gens qui se marient met de l'argent à
leur mariage
anonyme on craque un peu fameux suis pas
marié mais les gens craquent un peu la
bourse pour faire faire un beau mariage
à proportion de leurs moyens ils
dépensent beaucoup d'argent ce soit de
bon ou de mauvais goût on est d'accord
ne vous savez ce qu'on dit hein l'amour
rend aveugle le mariage brandon la vue
de payer trop d'argent pour la personne
qui répond voilà enfin vous qui n'êtes
pas mariée donc justement ça me coûte
recherche sont pas débourser d'argent là
dedans quelle folie vous croira dînerez
vous a sauvé pour moi c'est naze
mondiaux est ce qui me gêne et je trouve
ça naze parce que plus on met de
l'argent dans un mariage plus on
affaires des prestataires qui ce que
pour vous d'organiser la fête et au
final vous avez un truc qui vous
ressemblent jamais donc pour quelque
chose qui sans cette la célébration
amoureuse dont quelque chose de très
personnel vous avez le truc qui coûte le
plus cher le plus impersonnel au monde
tellement il ya un vrai paradoxe pas si
je ne pouvais pas tout contrôler et vous
même si c'est ça le kiff justement c'est
d'aller justement avec les prestataires
s'occuper organisé cd souvenir que tu
gagnes précédemment il organise le
mariage dont le rêve est pas celui dont
le coût est pas obligé de débourser
d'argent qu'on te souviens